Hola Muy buenos días Muchas gracias
Bueno tras un año de guerra y desde la
perspectiva de una organización de
acción humanitaria que trabaja en el
sector salud como la nuestra
cuyo objetivo es preservar la vida a
través de la protección de la salud
reducir el sufrimiento de la población
claro no podemos hacer un balance
positivo en absoluto o sea hoy a fecha
de hoy prácticamente el 40%
de la población ucraniana sería
subsidiaria de ayuda humanitaria
ha habido 7.000 víctimas mortales
directas por el conflicto
acerca de 20.000 personas
contraumatismos físicos como
amputaciones fracturas etcétera y luego
pues claro decenas de miles de personas
con los traumas psicológicos como el
estrés postraumático los trastornos
adaptativos
el agravamiento de procesos
de Salud Mental y también consecuencias
en la atención a otro tipo de patologías
comunes y graves como pueden ser los
procesos oncológicos las enfermedades
crónicas como la diabetes la
hipertensión las enfermedades
cardiovasculares cardíacas etcétera que
están sufriendo las consecuencias de la
rupturas de suministros de la rupturas
de la existencia por falta por ejemplo
de provisión de suministro eléctrico en
los centros asistenciales y también
porque ha habido ataques directos a
infraestructuras sanitarias hemos
contabilizado por encima de 100
infraestructuras dañadas o destruidas de
hecho se han producido también por
encima del centenar de muertes en
personal sanitario y más de un centenar
unas decenas por encima de centenar de
personas heridas no queremos decir con
esto que las infraestructuras sanitarias
sean objetivo militar pero sí que no se
respeta el derecho nacional humanitario
en cuanto a preservar las instituciones
de asistencia médica la actividad de las
organizaciones humanitarias los
corredores humanitarios para la
provisión de ayuda y realmente no se han
respetado Durante este año que también
como consecuencia de la guerra Pues hay
8 millones de personas ucranianas que
han abandonado su país y aproximadamente
pues cerca de por encima de 5 millones
Perdón que han sido desplazadas
internamente señor Fernández según su
informe es difícil que en un país como
Ucrania las personas afectadas busquen
asesoramiento psicológico porque
bueno
en Ucrania como en cualquier país del
mundo creo que pesa un estigma sobre
todo lo que es son problemas de Salud
Mental pero es que además digamos que en
unas condiciones como las actuales
el expresar el dolor el sufrimiento la
el quebranto en Salud Mental pues es
considerado como una fragilidad O
debilidad por parte de las personas de
tal manera que médicos del mundo ha
organizado por ejemplo atención directa
en los centros de acogida a la población
desplazada atención directa en zonas
Rurales atención directa en zonas de
Refugio de la población cuando se
producen alertas de ataques etcétera no
Y también estamos trabajando en la
organización y en la formación de las de
profesionales
sanitarios ucranianos para la atención
directa en la salud mental de la
población